Amy and Jared this is from Amy welcome
to my hometown of San Diego all right
we're all in favor San Diego you don't
need to cheer it I don't know if you
know this but you love sandy no [ __ ]
I'll beat the show the twenty second
boyfriend Jared he introduced me to your
show and I've been hooked ever since of
the shout-out is for him it's very sweet
Amy we come here to celebrate our
anniversary but our anniversary isn't
for our first date or our first kiss or
even the first time we said I love you
to one another it was the first time we
met got plastered and [ __ ] stand up
stand up stand up you two alright
alright you know it's a lot to [ __ ] an
Amish guy wait wait wait show us how you
did it
alright easy was it all the same night
you met got plastered and [ __ ] all the
same no that's that expect how long rows
this how long what I this is six years
ago right on man look at that there's a
[ __ ] total wonderful advertisement
for casual unsafe sex with a strand well
they went through the stages then they
became friends with benefits they [ __ ]
and then they became must be friends but
keep [ __ ] em no no they [ __ ] they
became a horrible movie
then eventually something a little more
serious happened just like in the movie
six years later here we are celebrating
the closest thing we have to an
anniversary hopefully laughing our asses
off then maybe ending the night drunk
and naked just for nostalgic purposes
well there's more purposes than that
purposes of orgasm that would she be
your purposes can you please in your
Harrison Ford voice tell Jared happy
anniversary and that if I'm drunk enough
and he's lucky enough he just might find
out what Princess Leia really meant by
into the garbage chute flyboy
[Applause]
ami adds yes that would be a really
nerdy reference to anal sex this is the
greatest weekend of my life just take
her in the backseat the Millennium
Falcon shitty dick wait wait mr. Ford
while you have their attention don't
forget to plug Cowboys and Aliens
[Music]
Cowboys an alien
[Music]
oh stop save it for the end that's what
my wife says is that did that do it is
he gonna get it after after that stage
er what's the next stage she's got to
get drunk enough how many drinks have
you I want to make sure this happens
just one oh come on girl always remember
comic-con man yeah the comic guns a
horrible place where you hurt my hiney
even our marriage almost last night when
I gave up the garbage chute it was
supposed to be a Star Wars Joe you took
it seriously
Threepio get us out of here oh my
goodness he's dying inside of her
[ __ ] that's no moon
[Music]
you
[Music]